jail
is statistics you can laugh and you can
see and even and even and even and you
can quantify all yours well X as much as
you like but you're still just throwing
random numbers that don't actually have
any okay okay I can't even tell you like
just anecdotally and like so just from
talking to people day to day like I I
have nine siblings same two parents
we've adopted three and like when I talk
to people that come from single parent
homes about like my family's Traditions
every year like I've never seen like
such like like they want that so bad
it's really sad like they've never
experienced like no I'm sorry sorry I'm
laughing at something else
um no it's it's sad though like they've
never experienced like Christmas with
both parents together like and then all
the traditions we do like we do pictures
with Santa every year we do like an
Easter egg hunt like like family's
really big and I I just see like the
loss that's someone's out when they
didn't get to grow up with two parents
and I just wouldn't wish that upon
anyone but I think I think again that
comes down to two parents yes but also
having adults that love you right and
adults that are a team that can raise
you right because that's a big family
and you have Traditions but you can have
Traditions lots of different family
Dynamics right and the polyamorous room
right one team comes together to raise a
kid you can still build Traditions well
it's just a bit of a different Dynamic
but I think I think it's better like we
kind of did have a a team raise us
because like we had we had help and we
also had like relatives that stepped in
my grandma's like I could name you a
long list of people that helped and
stepped in but I think it's better when
it's like in the family and it's all
what's the difference between a
community that you build in a community
that's biological like what's I would
say I would say it's it's like more
vetted and so like you're happy because
you're going around people that have
known each other for years for a year
like and well more vetted that like
because family members are um no but
family members are they they can be that
person who sexually abuses you know it
is possible to happen right that's not
not gonna happen you're correct but I
would say that it's easier to like I put
it
like everyone knows who the weird uncle
is everyone everyone knows exactly uncle
is in the family and you keep your kids
away from the weird uncle and I'm not
saying it doesn't happen but I
it just anecdotally would guess that it
happens at a much lower rate when it's
family than when it's random people that
you've met I don't know if you'd be able
to can I just say because I want to go
back to what something that you said
because I said that children need two
biological parents and you said that
they don't yeah right
how do you reconcile that a child who
was born of two people
doesn't need those two people
how do you reconcile like how how do you
say they don't need that if that if
that's how they came into the world
so so my entire existence I was raised
by someone who wasn't my biological
parent and he's my father and he's one
would you raise my was your mother there
your biological mother my biological
mother was there yes and I was raised by
my stepfather who wasn't my biological
father and he had I've had four sisters
two were from a relationship prior to
him being with my mother and then he had
two sisters he had two daughters with my
mother and he was do you know do you
know your biological father at all you
do yes I do so you don't have a
relationship with him I don't have a
massive relationship with him but I've
had I've like I've had a a like we're
not I don't dislike him I don't like as
a child if we go back to your childhood
yes did you want to know who your father
was I knew him
I did know him okay yeah like okay but
you were you were you were lucky you had
someone step in you did have two parents
in the home yeah and but I'm saying not
every kid is that lucky yeah but like
and you had a good and you had a good
step father of course but of course but
that wasn't that wasn't the argument
that you always put to me but you
already knew him so imagine you didn't
know him you don't think that children
want to know their biological parents
well so like until I was old enough to
be able to actually like with my human
brain Quantified that he would like what
the difference was between my stepdad
and my real dad I didn't I didn't know
did I and then I was I was I was
introduced to that and I was explaining
the Dynamics of that of that situation
and I was able to to to comprehend all
that and I've grown up pretty damn fine
as far as uh yeah I might be I might be
confusing to to you definitely confusing
to me yeah yeah yeah but you know I I
know I'm not I'm not normally down with
the podcast button no I hate you I hate
you but it's good to like you know
engage but
but like the point is you were lucky you
had a good step dad yeah but that's not
every kid right of course but but but
but but what like but like what who has
a better incentive that a kid turns out
good than both of the biological parents
who is more incentive to make sure that
kid turns out okay well my biological
dad wanted to have me aborted so that
happens yeah
did he tell you that
yes he told you that he wanted to have
you avoid yes you don't think that a
confirmative about it yeah you don't
think that had an effect on your
psychological at all no
no because I'm not a [ __ ] idiot I
like I I'm I'm well aware that sometimes
things happens in life and you you like
circumstances are out of our control and
sometimes I know if like yeah your
biological parent told you that he
didn't want that they didn't want you
here you don't think they had an effect
on your psychology at all nah no lots of
other things about effects on my
psychology but I don't think that did I
don't know your life okay I'm just gonna
say okay yeah no no like yeah I'm like
yeah okay I came here to challenge these
idea no no I hate you okay yeah if you
touch a leg it's just like I'm I'm doing
my job I'm doing a jam
do your thing man do you think uh pal um
we're gonna have to wrap up soon yeah so
we might have to read the rest of the
super chats all right don't I'm sorry
you probably got about a thousand yeah
let's see let's sail there we go
don't shoot the messenger
um okay KCF sack shout out to King
Richie's in the chat writing for your
reaction to this cluster f
um Wizard or shout out king Richie um
wizard ape um facts as embryos are
exposed to endocrine distributors in the
womb men can be born with shortened
distance of the tank correlation with
the men having discreased testosterone
Not all men are the same
um Al Draco malfo Draco Malfoy is PMSing
um B Jokers
I'm 35 years old and I've never met my
dad trust me it sucks as a man
um Bazi I can tell the middle simp loves
Andrew Tate
um Mark Peru Purdue the statistics first
step parents are comparable to single
Parenthood in some cases in some cases
worse it has to be when they're four or
less wizard ape the wall and feminine
urge for monogamy are reproductive urge
feminism will trick you into breaking
your ability to pattern Bond and you'll
instead fall into a loop of failed
relationships
um Mosin 1938 and polygamous situation
ships do you meet the other sexual
partners and do you ask your sexual
partner to get tested regularly 93 times
polygamy as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible